all right we're live
hello everyone hi welcome to
another episode of connecting the dots
today on the show
i have tara z manixek
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today
uh so tara i'm very happy to be here
i mean i and i'm just like i'm pumped
because i i have
joked many times that you are like the
most interesting person
in tech um because it seems like
every time i mention anything
like i'll be like oh yeah i'm working on
like a part of my kitchen you're like oh
yeah back when i was a plumber
um and so you just you kind of have like
this
incredibly diverse background in terms
of
where you what you've done for jobs what
you've done for work
um so i guess to start maybe we can we
can um
tee it off with where you are now what's
your current role
i am um at this company called netlify
i'm not sure if you've heard of it
nice to meet you by the way
i am on the the dx team uh mostly
working
with angular and then a bunch of really
fun internal products
like uh jam stack explorers so that's
where i currently am
absolutely um and so this uh
to me this is like this is the perfect
show for you because i feel
like sorry hold on let me just take a
second to congratulate myself on the
brilliance of
my name is jason i made this show and
it's perfect
let me tell you more but so let me
qualify that what i mean by this
is that this show is actually um it's
the result of a conversation that you
and i had
which was um we were talking about
how the skills that we build when we
work in different jobs
translate so well into tech in really
unexpected ways and so
in the past you know you and i have both
had non non-traditional
like we're not you you don't have a cs
degree right
i do you do oh my god you get more and
more interesting
okay all right well maybe i should let
you tell your own story then
[Laughter]
isn't that isn't that ridiculous though
i mean it's
uh it's it's funny because it's actually
from the harvard extension school
uh and i i got it because
i met so i'm a business school dropout i
tried to go to business school
i failed so miserably they were
because i was like oh these business
classes aren't fun i'm just going to go
to my
math classes in ceramics and classical
guitar classes and they're like yeah
you can't do that and i was like oh um
so i dropped out of there
and then ended up working um at
harvard and so i uh
got they have this tap program tuition
assistance program
so you can take courses for twenty
dollars at their extension school as
long as you can like
get in and uh i just kept being like
i started with it was like a physical
and screen based computing
class that was actually through mit uh
but we were allowed to take it
and i liked it so much i they used
processing
with java it was when processing was
like kind of new ish so it was only used
with java
and so i was like oh i want to be better
at making silly designs i should learn
java
and so that's how i learned java
and from there they were like well you
could be better at this if you learn
data structures and i was like
okay in order to make my really stupid
silly electronics
video games i am going to continue to
learn data structures
and it just went from there and
eventually i had a cs degree
jeez yeah okay uh every time we talk i
learned something new
um
but so uh so what are some of the other
jobs that you've held
uh in addition to being a coder
so i was actually looking back and i
haven't
had a break from the okay
so i've started working in 1995
and the longest break i've ever had
without a job
was the maternity leave that i took
about two years ago so and sometimes
i've like overlapped jobs
um and it's funny because thinking about
like my first real office job was when i
sounds so ridiculous when i was 12 years
old
um because you can't work until you're
14
in ohio but i or is is i don't know is
that everywhere
i think it's different from state to
state
so i but i had a taste of it because i
had started my own wagon business
obviously
um and which first i was
which i took pumpkin rolls around to
business districts and sold them
inside of the little you know where it's
like a brick log building and there's
like 18 businesses in there
so i did that um and so you know
door-to-door pumpkin roll sales as one
does
when they're that old uh and then i
painted curbs and stuff and this was all
because
i wanted to buy a flute
okay so i so at that point i was just
like learned
okay i need money to get things
therefore i like sell goods
um and then from there i was just like
you know
this isn't enough i need more money
[Laughter]
one for each nostril and
so but then so my grandmother was like
well come
to barberlin foods and you can be my
payroll assistant you really like
math so um you can do payroll for
everybody
and the funniest thing is like i learned
really good people skills there because
my grandma is such a little schmoozer
uh she used to be yeah so she like did
she did a lot of office management work
for a while and then when she retired
she became
a bartender at the vfw as grandmas do
um and so she was like the thing that
you have to understand is
people just want you to listen to them
if you listen to them and you
genuinely find something to care about
like of them then they'll
they'll warm up to you faster and
they'll give you the better benefit of
the doubt
um and it's funny because she's uh known
as being quite a like cold
sarcastic woman and she was doing that
to her own advantage
but when i learned that i learned it as
such a
like real genuine trait that i really
have when i meet people i want to hear
more about them
and then i just like even if they're
people that
aren't the most likable people i always
try to find at least one thing that i
find
uh either like very intriguing
or it's something i like about them and
always try to keep that in mind at the
forefront
which has helped me a lot in the tech
industry
i can imagine um so so that's
fascinating so that was
like that takes us up to what you were
13.
so uh this is this is a five hour
episode right
um but so so along the way you you so
you started out you
you had you know your your pumpkin roll
business
um you you work doing the books
and then you you've like
you ended up at some point doing like
you were driving a forklift right
so that's actually like
13 years later or is that right
maybe maybe like 12 or something um so
i've had a lot of
uh retail experience and um
through a lot of different uh companies
like like looking through the list
it's been like a lot of like food and
retail things
uh i worked at subway target texas
roadhouse panera bridge chipotle pacific
summer
urban outfitters and bigs
this is the one where i was doing the
forklift because
i was working in um the garden center
okay so i would get all of the pallets
back and forth of mulch and stone and
everything
but i think like one of the things that
i learned the most
from those jobs that has helped me a lot
is
like from the retail jobs in particular
is that
uh customer service and common sense go
hand in hand
and i think that uh there
you just have to have the only emotion
that you should have
in customer service is empathy
because if you get angry if you
if you just say if you feel attacked if
you get defensive
that's going to take you nowhere fast
and it's funny because i think like
especially with working with open source
software
that has really helped me a ton
because it's so easy for me to get
defensive
about my code um
but when somebody is saying like this
isn't working for me
and why did you write it this way and i
have to remember how frustrated i get
when i use libraries and i say
why did they do it this way this does
not work this api is so it's bonkers
it's backwards whatever
um and so when i see things coming my
way i know i don't want
an author of a plug-in to be like i'm
not gonna help you because
uh you know you're a jerk
or you know there's a and
it's like so it's like i don't want to
be a jerk and i don't want to be a jerk
to you and there's been multiple times
um especially in issues and stuff where
people are like
your product sucks this is stupid what
are you doing this is awful
and so i just come back and i think
about it and i
try it like but keep my best to like
um take myself out of that situation
like like i did when i was like
doing target returns and they're like
your stupid store
said that i had to bring this back
and i'm like okay i see this is really
frustrating because you need this thing
to work
and you know i just you know i'm here
one-on-one with you
how can we make this work and just drop
all that
drama part of it to see if we can get to
a solution
and that like writing back to people's
angry issues like that
i've had so many times where people come
back and they go oh
you know i was really upset sorry for
the things that i said yeah
here's my problem here's the code what
can we do
yeah but that's hard there's a lot of
emotion in code we write
and and like what you're talking about
too it um
it kind of reminds me of like you know
they say that uh
like the the laws of thermodynamics like
every every action has an equal and
opposite reaction right
what i've found though is that in human
interactions that's not true
human interactions tend to mirror each
other which is why when somebody
comes at you hard and you get defensive
if you go back it will get
really contentious but if somebody comes
at you hard and you
don't you you like just let the
the anger wash over you and you just
respond as
measured as you can and and like nothing
comes back
so it's really hard for them to stay mad
like it's really hard you know what i
mean it's that whole idea of like
it's so hard to like
attack somebody who's peaceful like
peaceful resistance kind of thing like
so if somebody's coming at you
you know and you just say i understand
and i want to help
no you don't know the person
who's coming at you um
oh sorry i think i had a little delay
you're fine you're back
okay bye am i here um
so i was just gonna say that i think we
talk about this or we don't talk about
this enough but just like
understanding that our jobs aren't our
whole lives
and so when people come at you angry you
don't know where they're coming from
and so i did americorps national
civilian community court
and we did katrina disaster relief so
right right after all the floods we went
down
and we like gutted houses and
you know worked at different volunteer
bases and
basically like just entrenched ourselves
in these areas that were just
demolished and uh
you had it was hard to because you would
get so desensitized from living in these
areas
it was hard to remember what people were
going through so we would have
like i remember having a situation where
i was uh
in one of the volunteer camps and this
guy came in and he was like
just went off on us uh because our truck
was
parked in front of his driveway and we
didn't even know anybody was there
so we were just like huh
and he was screaming and i don't do well
with people screaming
uh but i had
at first we were all just like what how
dare you like
sorry that's my dog um
but then you realize like oh yeah
this guy doesn't have a place to live
anymore he's coming home to his house
being completely and you can't even get
in the driveway now
and so i think about that kind of
mindset
when you know people come at you
already at a level 10 and you're just
like dude
all it was is that you know that part of
the module needed installed like why are
you yelling already
and then you're just like oh yeah your
boss is yelling at you
to get this done immediately and their
boss is yelling at them
and like there's a whole trickle down
and you just know
that yelling is happening and you should
be yelling too
and i also think like in open source
there's this
this tendency where like in the early
days of open source it's really fun
because when you're a maintainer
everybody who's coming to your library
is they're voluntarily there they want
to try something out
there they're there to learn and to like
be part of a community
later as something gets popular like you
know if you're a webpack maintainer
right now
most of the people in the webpack issues
they're not there because they wanted to
learn webpack they're there because they
inherited a project
and they're on a deadline and something
is broken and they don't understand it
and they didn't write this code to begin
with
and they're furious that they have to
deal with this problem because they
don't feel like it should be their
problem
and unfortunately you as the maintainer
are the person
standing right in front of them when
they're having this realization
and i think yeah i mean i i love i love
that way of framing it though because if
you think about the fact that
people don't exist in a vacuum you know
if you if you assume that people
exist when they're outside of your your
field of view
they've got whole stories they've got
whole lives going on and the thing
that's happening to you right now has
very little to do with you if this isn't
somebody you know
exactly exactly and it's funny because
you know like they say
software is easy people are hard and i
think
i think that a lot that a lot that i
learned from getting my cs degree
is um and i i
so i was really lucky my mom taught
electronics at the local community
college
and so when i would get out of school i
would go to
her like her electronics lab and just
fiddle around with breadboards and stuff
so i got taught the mindset of logical
thinking
uh thanks to that really uh analog
procedure of like this thing is feeding
this thing and it can only get these
instructions it can only be on or off
and where is that on or off going and
who is it telling us what's on and off
so i was really lucky to have that kind
of like logical mindset
pretty early on and then that got really
reinforced
once i started going through uh all my
cs courses and it's kind of like
which i think you can learn from not
even just classes but doing
uh development work in general um
but i definitely saw when the switch
flipped
you know when you're like you're making
dinner after coating something out and
you're like
pot turn boil water boil
when water boils pasta
what's happened to my brain
and it's just like i remember just
thinking of like my dog's different
methods
and i was just like what's happening
um but that is such
a that's a factor in a development job
the human communication that has to go
to make a functioning
team and a functioning product is
something that like you don't have to
have 38 jobs like i have had
but it definitely helps to have such a
mixture of
one like working or dealing with
both people that you need to manage
people that are on your
all people that you need to manage
people that are on your team and people
that are managing you
and i think i learned a ton from the
different kinds of jobs i had and the
different responsibilities i had in each
of those jobs
um so i i'm going to make one quick
comment which is that when you when
you're talking about your
your uh like writing the code for making
pasta
the italians in chat are very grateful
that you said when
water then pasta
which i also uh well done
um but uh another question so there was
a question
earlier you talked about getting your
css your cs degree and
when you were learning data structures
and pranav asks
uh how is your experience learning data
structures and like what of that do you
find has been important in your
in your roles or in your career i guess
it's funny because it was definitely a
lot of
you know now i didn't it wasn't that
long ago that i went to school
but now they have so many hilarious
resources like
uh like bubble sort square dancing
videos and
i saw that
and i'm like oh yeah that would make i
had a real i had a really great teacher
um and and so he did a lot of things
like the whole tearing of the notebook
uh to kind of show you different kinds
of ways to like sort
uh that class was by far one of my
hardest because i had only done like
intro to java before then so that like
logical mindset wasn't completely
ingrained in me
it's funny to think how i use it now
because
i'm not anytime i need to do a data
structure some kind of
like principle along those lines i go
back to reference
constantly so there's nothing in my head
that i'm yeah then i'm this like oh well
it's obviously this
because of that um
that's cassidy cassidy's the one that
does that um
it's cassidy williams that we're
referring to
obviously um but uh
i do i do have that mindset though of
like
yeah we're we're setting um
we have to have these different markers
to understand
what is the best process to make this
faster and like we were talking about
this in
um on remotely interesting a podcast we
do uh
skype weird guy jason's on there too
and we talked about rendering in this
one episode
and it's funny because in everything we
have these markers so like we have
uh like you know time to first
contentful paint
and like time like we're all we're
marking everything so that we
have a system to understand what how
it's going to be better for our users
and so it's more that i'm not bringing
any data structures with me on a daily
basis
but it's more that mindset of like our
there is an algorithm to figure out how
to make this best for our users
and that mentality has definitely stuck
through and through
yeah the rest of that class though i
mean i so i i don't have a cs degree but
what i
what i have found about things like
algorithms data structures that type of
study
is i very rarely am looking at that
information and saying that's exactly
what i'm going to do to solve this
problem
but what i what i found is that having
that
around in the back of my mind when i
look at a problem i at least have a list
of things to like
thumb through and go is that kind of
like this is that kind of like this and
then i can go
i at least know what to google right and
i i think that's been
probably the most beneficial part of any
of that more academic learning for me
has been it it gives me vocabulary that
lets me google more effectively
yeah yeah which is i mean it's it's
hilarious to me when i try to tell
people just how much
googling is part of our job like and
it's funny because that's another one
that i've learned
through so many different jobs is
to ask for help not just like
searching things on the web but it's
like
it takes a lot of humility to
one admit you did something wrong and
then on top of
it ask for help um but it's just
it's totally clutch like you
nobody's perfect and uh if you are
turns out you're wrong
so uh but but it's definitely like
through the years i've definitely had to
like
tell myself remind myself that it's just
like
okay you even about things that don't
have
like a specific right answer just
knowing that you may think this is the
best way to go about doing something
but you're not working in a silo so
you have to like i remember the first
time our
uh our the vp of
development experience at netlify sarah
drazner
said to disagree and commit i just
remember being like
oh what
and then it's just like oh yeah because
team
like company business it's like
yeah it makes sense like you've got to
do that in your daily life i've also
been in a relationship for like
too long what 12 years or something
oh 14. um and i mean half
at least three quarters of the
relationship is disagree and commit
so you learn from everywhere in your
life
yeah well and actually i think that's
kind of a so you mentioned one thing
that i think is really hard
to start because especially when you're
new in your career
the idea of of admitting that you don't
know something that can feel like it's
going to be the giveaway that gets you
like thrown out you know it's like oh
they're going to realize that i don't
know what i'm doing
for for you how like
how was that experience and like how did
what experiences did you have that
helped you overcome that fear of saying
like hey i don't know how to do this who
who can help me
i've always liked to learn um and
having having the
having the craving to learn has
overcompensated
that whole pride thing um and
but it was definitely something that i
learned i realized that i made a better
uh
team member in in the develop in the dev
world
because i had uh
i had learned a lot so much from all the
other jobs that i've
been on like i didn't know how to
like um so i like renovated a house
recently and like i didn't know the
proper way to like cut and install
drywall
how to do plumbing how the different
angles matter if you actually want your
poop
to go down um
and so so it's definitely a lot
of being like there's something like i
had the the overseer of of doing
a lot of the construction work uh i i
worked with habitat for humanity for a
little while
and we actually built houses on the um
on the uh mall in dc okay
so it was like this really cool event
where they had 12 houses
and we built them on the mall and then
they got on trucks and moved them out to
different places around
like anacostia and the area was
so cool and uh the foreman on the
project
was so mean and you don't really
expect it for like these programs that
are like
let's all work together um and he just
expected you to know everything
and so we would be putting things
together and i'm like i don't know how
to do this
but the last thing you want to go is
like go up to the bully and be like i'm
dumb
because he just was like what do you
mean you don't know how to frame a house
and i'm like i'm i don't know i
also had like 16 jello shots last night
so
let's work together um but
i feel like when when you have that
experience of just like
okay this is the boss right like the
boss in a video game
but like his defense is like being a
jerk to you
and then how you're gonna or like his
attack is being object to you and then
your defense is just like
taking it and knowing that he
has not doesn't know anything about you
he can't really
change your life in any horrible way
so the only thing that can happen here
is that i can just
let those things slide off me and learn
what i need to learn
and that's an extreme situation like
hopefully not a lot of people
are like having insults thrown at them
as they're trying to hammer two by fours
together
but uh it made me even
be better at like the first dev job i
had
um i kind of like i knew what i was
doing but i had always
worked with uh i was like switching to
do more back end work
and i was also unfamiliar with
infrastructure
and so it would look like i knew what i
was doing so my managers would be like
yeah that's right just keep doing what
you're doing i'm like it looks like i
know what i'm doing but i don't
so explain this to me on this selection
and this section is if i don't know what
i'm doing
right and i felt like that was a really
good thing that i'm
glad i had in my toolbox um
to even say like yeah sure you think
i'm doing it right but i'm not
i i don't know what i'm doing because
that's hard it's hard
one to just say you don't know what
you're doing and especially when you're
new
and you're like they could they just
brought me on like
they could get rid of me if they wanted
but it's also
it's really good to remember i'm gonna
take a breath talking after this point
it's good to remember with both um like
many things in life but development and
definitely
speaking like doing talks
especially technical talks people don't
want to see you
fail like 97.63 people
don't want to see you fail it's
extremely awkward as an audience member
it's very uh it's not it's not what
managers want to see
so they're rooting for you when it comes
down to it so if they can
find a way to help you succeed as a
manager the audience can't
if they can find a way to help you
succeed as one of their employees
that's what they want to do so if you
can give them what they need to let them
know what you need to succeed
right like it's making everybody happier
nobody yeah nobody wants to see you fail
so yeah well and really like if somebody
hired
you it's gonna look really bad on them
if the person they hired is like not
equipped to do the job so it's in there
like even just selfishly it's in your
manager your
your employer's best interest to train
you so you know
and if they do want to see you fail you
don't want to work there yeah
fair enough right um but so so we've
been kind of talking like this is
this is a lot of abstract stuff that i
think is really really helpful but
um for a lot of folks watching this
stream um
they're in free code camp and a lot of
those folks are looking for their first
role
so when you are like i know that you do
a decent amount of mentorship i know
that you work with a lot of communities
you've been in the industry for a while
so i don't i mean i have a hard time
remembering how i got my first role
outside of like i did a thing and then i
had a job but
um but what advice do you have like
the industry is flooded right now there
are a lot of people looking for their
first job there's
also a little bit of constriction due to
the pandemic
companies are looking for it seems like
everybody's only hiring senior devs or
they're saying
entry level but they're putting three
years experience into the into the job
description so
for someone who's looking for that first
break for someone who is looking to
stand out
in a large sea of applicants for a very
limited number of entry level roles
what advice do you have that can help
somebody you know
get that first chance i think the
biggest thing
is um people are afraid to put their
work on
get to have it somewhere online
because they're like well i don't really
know what i'm doing
i think so i don't want to
um you know like have have evidence
online that i did something wrong but
like
if you look at jason's old code he did
tons of things wrong
absolutely and jason's brilliant so well
it's like you know case study right
there
um but i think uh
it's especially for people who are i
work with a lot of women in tech
um organizations and just like
actual women who are doing development
and especially
um when i was i started at the branch of
women who code in cincinnati
and the biggest thing i got was a lot of
people re-entering the field
and uh it's it's daunting to go
in and talk to people who are also
looking at applicants that are coming
straight out of cs courses and they're
young and they've
you know we've been working with
computers since they were three months
old
and you know it's like well i've been
out of the industry you know do i know
what i'm doing
and one of your kindest audiences are
the people who aren't paying you
so especially right now when
brick-and-mortars are really hurting
and there's an opportunity for a lot of
companies to
go online but they
can't afford it they need that help
look into those projects even if it's
like working with one person from your
community and saying
okay i'm gonna have to take the
knowledge that i've learned through boot
camps through doing things on my own
and uh put that into an actual product
because one you're going to learn so
much from that
not only just how hard customers are
work
are to work with but also like um you
know
how do you want to set up your
infrastructure you know how are you
going to have it so that people can use
it on mobile
like there are so many things that
you're going to learn from just doing
one actual small
project like i do a side project with uh
the uh i cannot get this acronym right
um but it's basically the asian american
association
of cincinnati and so we've put a site
together
um actually using like gatsby and
netlify
and strappy to uh basically get all of
these different
asian business owners um onto one site
it's uh asianati
uh.com and that way
uh it's hard for restaurants right now
to just like you're not gonna walk by a
restaurant and be like oh i'm gonna go
in there and eat
because we're all inside in front of our
team our tv is watching queen's gambit
and so like this gives them a way to be
in front of an audience
um all in one central location but i'm
doing it for free
uh but i'm learning so much uh
and and then you have an actual physical
working thing that you can
show employers so if you know you're
more of an introvert or like
like me you hate saying anything uh good
about yourself to anybody but yourself
then it's nice because you can just let
your work speak for you
and uh i i find that i find it really
rewarding because you also
if you can find a non-profit like that
you get to work with a team
but also um if you're doing it by
yourself just to help out a company
uh one it's great you help out somebody
in your neighborhood
or a small business and two you can make
all the decisions yourself which is also
really fun
yeah well and the other thing that that
does when you work with
non-profits or groups like that is you
you start building a network
um because i know like for me i i got my
first job in montana
and in montana there are no
jobs like it's not not well there are
now i guess but at the time there just
wasn't
a lot of technology companies there and
i hadn't been
introduced to the idea of remote work so
i was like okay well i gotta find a job
in missoula montana that's my option
and the only way that i was able to do
that
was by hanging out at a developer's
meetup and finding people
who were working at different companies
and one of them got a lead on a client
but they didn't have time so they passed
it to me and that was my first paying
client
so those types of jobs are are
really like that now that's on my resume
where it was on my resume at the time
you know it was like
now i've got a real paying client look
i'm a professional and not
i'm not looking for my first break i'm
looking for my second job
and it changed the whole narrative it
changed the discussion all the way
from like hey please give me my first
break to hey i've been doing this
professionally i'm looking for something
new
and it immediately changed the way that
things worked and that was all due to a
network
um so i think like getting involved in
those projects getting
finding ways where you can work with
other people in the industry
just long enough to be on a first name
basis with them you know like
have have like the idea of friends in
high places it's not
it's not what you know it's who you know
all those things are cliches for a
reason
they're cliches because they work um and
so you know
in now that everything's remote right
like you know i
how how do you feel that's changed for
you how is your your social network
changed
in the the age of like remote everything
was funny because i also got my first
tech job
out of school through a meetup um and
that was like the big
the big thing to me was i just kept
finding things that i liked to do
and so uh this company was
uh they had a meetup and i was i was
like kind of trying to choose between if
i wanted to do
um if i wanted to work more with like
ruby
ruby on rails and stuff or go into the
node
uh side of things and so there was a
tesl
meetup so tessel is
an open source microcontroller library
and it's all run on node and
i was i love i love just like taking or
tinkering around with electronics
still like soldering is one of my
favorite pastime because of the fumes
and so we we went into this
meetup and i didn't know anybody there
and so i just
uh kind of talked to people and
one person i just like hit it off with
he got a 40 in a brown bag and i was
like is that king cobra and he was like
how did you know that and i was like no
no um and but then he was like talking
he was like oh here's my card and i was
like oh pragmatic or he's like a
software craftsman and i was like oh
like pragmatic programmer
um which is a really great book and uh
then he was like are you looking for a
job and i was like oh yeah i am
and he i ended up working for this uh
platform as a service company and i
loved everybody there and it was like
you can't do that now like it's hard to
get
you you know you can't go in person and
just chat about whatever's going
on but that's kind of really great for
introverts because
now there are different ways to
communicate um
and virtual tech conferences a lot of
them are free right now like jamsatconf
was all free
and are different like networking things
that you can do inside there
but also people are more inclined to be
online and in front of their computers
so
one of the biggest things that i always
push people to do who are coming
back into the industry is to
email any contact in a department that
they were interested in
uh in the company like just shoot out a
cold email
just try uh because
job descriptions are and job listings
are horrible
like netlifies i highly recommend
checking those out if like you want to
see
what it should look like obviously i'm
super biased but
it's like i i remember when i first
started looking for jobs
it would be like oh you should know um
you should know every single back-end
language would be listed
and i'm just like why why and it's
because whoever was in that department
to make the job description was like
oh uh software languages
okay i'll list those okay what else like
and so there's so much there like that
doesn't make sense
so i think especially like in these
times where nobody's really meeting up
and talking
you have uh there could be a slight
advantage to being able to reach out to
people
and it's like it makes sense even to the
people you're reaching out to like oh
yeah i can't see this person
in person so communicating online you
can ask
questions and then you don't have that
pressure of like one-on-one being like
oh
what is job you know you can
re-read and definitely proofread
everything that you send out
um and that's a really nice thing
because it lets you
sink like really think about things
uh through before words out your mouth
are bad
[Laughter]
i i mean i like i'm laughing but that is
excellent advice like i really do think
that you know having more spaces being
created where people can
be slow and be considered and not
necessarily have to
immediately rapid fire think on your
feet to respond because
that is a whole different skill set that
you do have to practice and and
something that
none not all of us are ever going to be
comfortable with um
but so i have a couple questions from
the chat one
have you worked with software testing
professionally
i'm not sure if that question is is
directly at like
were you a test engineer or like
have you written tests as an engineer i
think the answer will be the way that
answer goes is slightly different based
on context but i'll let you take it
whichever way you want
yes to all of those but
because
[Laughter]
yes
so i um
i i because like the platform is a
service that i worked for
uh we were pretty small i was like
the uh besides the manager like the
third engineer hired on
and so we were touching everything
so definitely wrote a lot of tests and
i actually like test writing i it's like
i tend to make uh like once i switched
over to
more uh developer um
what's the one that's not developer
experience
[Music]
i don't know and i had to make a lot of
demos
um devrel is that what you're thinking
yeah
thank you yes um so when i switched over
to that i had to make a lot of demos
fast
and so at first in the beginning i would
write a lot more tests
because i enjoyed it um but then
that fell to the wayside when it was
like oh my talks tomorrow and i need a
demo
not that i ever do that um
but then actual testing uh
we had to do a lot of that for our
product uh at the platform as a service
so
yes yes um another question that i think
is
uh is very relevant is we were talking a
little bit earlier about
just building projects putting those out
in public and vivek is asking
will the pet projects help in cracking
an interview for a developer role
100 because that's
again i really liked the company that i
was working at the
hiring manager or like the engineering
managers were really good about having
the interview
be about uh like
what you know based on talking to you
so i did no whiteboarding in that first
interview
um which is good because any time i go
in front of a whiteboard i immediately
draw funny dinosaurs
but um they were like what is something
you learned um on a project that you
were doing
and you know tell me the code behind it
uh and that doesn't it you know
everybody's different but that didn't
feel very daunting to me
because it was like oh my gosh yeah when
i had to do this thing with this array
and you know this wasn't the right way
to sort through it so i had to go
through this way and i thought that
would work but then this thing was wrong
and so you're basically like venting
about a project that you're working on
but
in in that you're able to show
that like you had you could talk through
the code that you wrote and you
understood
what things were right what things were
wrong and
you've actually coded before yeah
like which sounds ridiculous
but um it's it's a way to know too
how frustrated people get on what
problems
and how much excitement they find in
coding
so um and you know what you they try to
stay
if they if they're if you're i've had
this before
where you're hiring somebody who's
supposed to mostly be working on back
end work
and all they want to talk about through
the whole interview is
the front-end stuff or you know stuff
that is not
right connected to what you're hiring
them for and
not that that's always a downfall but it
says like you're not really as excited
about
the aspect that we're hiring for well so
but that i think is such a good point
because like if if we're
writing a job description for a very
specific role and you are a great
developer who's not
interested in that specific role it's
not it's going to work out poorly for
both of us because you're you're not
going to be super passionate about the
work we are asking you to do
and you'll instead be trying to do work
that is you know
not what we were hiring for so it's
better
like actually that you reminded me of
the way we were interviewing on my team
at ibm
where one of the things that we would do
is we did a take-home
work project and we just it was like
okay you've got two hours
build a website and the things that we
wanted you to do for the website
were like you could build a front end
you could build the
the kind of like data business layer of
like how you load stuff in
or you could build it back in to store
that data and then we would look at what
people focused on because two hours is
not enough time to do the whole thing
so we said you know do do whatever you
would do and then at two hours just cut
off and then we'll talk about
you know what you would do next and all
that and if somebody spent the whole
time on the ui
we knew that that was where their
passion was if they spent the whole time
setting up a back end
we knew that was where their passion was
um and you could hear in the way they
talked about it
because you would see like well in some
i'd have to figure out how to build the
data
stuff and you could tell like that's not
the thing they're comfortable with it's
not the thing they're interested in
but they would just bubble and bubble
and bubble about how much fun it was
to write this front end and you're like
perfect that we needed a ui engineer
this is exactly who we should hire
um and so i and but you can see that in
projects too like you said like if
somebody is putting out a lot of pet
projects then
you get like a really good insight into
what they're
excited about what their what they're
building and what they're publishing
that's a window you know you're you're
telegraphing as a developer when you
build something
you're sending out a message that this
is what i like to build and
so if you've got a bunch of ui projects
and you're applying for a ui role that
sends a signal to me as a hiring manager
oh this person's doing exactly what we
want i'd i'd like to see more
and like if we're hiring for juniors
we're not looking for people who are
perfect we're looking for people who are
excited
because we're going to teach you the
skills but we can't teach you to be
excited about it
um yeah sorry you were going to say
something
i oh no i was going to say there's a lot
of
resiliency to be showcased in doing
side projects or pet projects um and
don't let
don't let the lack of an idea stumble
you
make you stumble because um
one thing that we were talking about i
think this is also unremotely
interesting
um and i think you actually brought up
this point
of almost like every profession
we're copying each other and we're
totally
totally
do that in tech all the time um and
that's one of the best ways to learn
like when you're playing a musical
instrument you're just playing the same
thing that someone's played over and
over and over
and so you know if you want to
you know try to make a buzzfeed
you know make a buzzfeed it's showing
that you can take a concept and put it
onto the screen
into actually working data and working
files and
so if you don't have an idea don't worry
about it if you think that your
idea is dumb that's fine
most ideas we have are dumb it's just
doing something yeah well and
realistically speaking like when you get
a job
as an engineer it won't be your idea
that you're building so
so rebuilding another thing is a great
example of like what it's like to work
for another company you're gonna get
handed a mock-up you're gonna get handed
a business goal
and told to build something and and sent
loose to do that
um and so that you know that's that's
not like
that that is not cheating by any means
that's actually closer to what you would
do on the day-to-day than
if you were to come up with something
completely on your own
yeah and just like so i know this idea i
said it before but again
if you'd go to a small business and
you're like let me
uh make your website for you
it's gonna be quite a journey i'm not
going to like sugar coat it like they're
going to be so grateful and do and
like whatever you like but that's going
to be part of a really great learning
process
is like knowing because this happens on
teams constantly where you're like here
i made this thing that you asked for
and they're like that's not exactly what
i asked for change all of it
okay cool so
it's i mean i i can't i can't stress
enough how like trying to find that in
your community or small business
somewhere it's like
it'll help you in the long run yeah
um okay so we have time for probably one
more question and i think there's a
really good one because we were just
talking about projects
um but there's a whole school of thought
and a lot of
emphasis especially in technical
interviews on the idea of
like the things that you would see in
white boarding so leak code
algorithmic you know being able to write
your own bubble sort by hand and all
that kind of stuff
um what it seems the messaging that's
being sent
is that doing those types of programming
puzzles
is a more it's going to have more of an
advantage when looking for a job
versus building projects do you do you
agree with that or kind of what's your
take on that
it's so it's such a loaded question
because there are definitely benefits
in someone being able to
make those mental maps and show it in
code
uh but i am i i lose it in interviews
i forget like i remember i had an
interview
and they were like what other frameworks
are there for node
and that is like like
koa and they're like yeah i like those
and it's like oh
there are other ones
in my github i have every single a
project made with every single node
framework
i because i found it interesting to try
every single one out
but in the interview i was like my
name's tara
[Laughter]
so i mean that in itself is like
you know white boarding stuff can be
actually really fun when you're
comfortable and you're on a team and
like
you are just part of like your work day
like i've definitely done it a lot
and in jobs that i've already chosen to
hire me
um but i just think that there are other
techniques to to
glean a lot more from candidates that
you will probably not be literally
whiteboarding with
in their position whatsoever right um
but there
there are like you know they're they're
way
it's like trying to say that a problem
is black and white
um because it's a cop-out it's a cop-out
to just be like well they've been
whiteboarding these problems for so long
we're just gonna keep doing it
if you want a good candidate put as much
effort into getting that candidate as
you want them to put into getting your
job
right um so try harder i guess
well and for the candidates too like i
think you know the
as much as this sucks to say the
algorithm stuff the the training for
coding interviews
that is like studying for the sats it
will help you score better
in the technical interview it will
likely have very little impact on your
ability
to succeed in your job so make sure
that while you're studying for technical
interviews you're also
doing real world type of work and the
projects are that real world
type of work so what like my my
preference if if i was gonna give advice
is to
spend most of your time building real
world projects and then if you are going
into a round of technical interviews
cram on technical interview stuff in the
meantime like
for the couple weeks leading up to it
like don't don't make don't become an
expert at taking tests that doesn't
serve you in the in the job market
uh become an expert at doing the work
that the the test will get you to
um and and you know honestly
there's a lot of pressure on tech
companies to revise the way that we're
doing technical interviews
and you know for example netify we've
dropped
like algorithmic whiteboarding as a
thing that we do we
we've moved to instead doing like
code samples you will you will implement
a feature you will
do it you know you'll do something
that's closer to real word world we're
not going to
remove your access to google and make
you write down code on a whiteboard
that's
it's not realistic that's not how you
would do your job so instead we want to
see how you think about things what
would you google how do you you know do
you have the
the requisite context to break this
problem down into things that you can
search for to find the information that
would let you solve it
because that to me is a sign of a good
developer not whether or not you've
memorized a bunch of
code um yeah if if i were to go on a job
interview right now
which i'm not no really not um but
i would i would definitely like
make a place that was easy for uh
prospective employers
to find my work and just like one or two
clicks be able to go
and look at my code go look at projects
i've made like make
it very accessible for them to get to
because if it's not part of their hiring
process
you know it you want them to see this
work so it's stuff that you're putting
your time into make it easy for them to
find it and to see it and make sure you
get it to them
and then like jason said there was a
cake walk there are a few there's so
many different resources out there that
can like give you a bunch of problem
examples i know
cassidy williams newsletter she has like
interview questions in each newsletter
right
um and she breaks down the solution too
so like you can
you can do it with a group which i think
is a great way to learn
a hundred percent um and yeah and then
also like uh
well you're like washing dishes they're
you know
doing something in your house you can
put on uh like all these for videos from
conferences where they talk about new
like newer breaking strategies and like
most
things that are like cutting edge to
just like
absorb the different things going around
in the community because
not only are you hearing the jargon but
you're keeping abreast of all the new
things going on so those are three
things that i would definitely keep in
mind
absolutely and i think that is a great
place to wrap up because we are
unfortunately out of time i feel like i
could talk about this with you
all day so with that i will say tara
thank you so so much
for for hanging out with us today um
where should people go if they want to
follow up with you
um i think quincy dropped your twitter
maybe i live
yeah i live on winik woods um
no uh yeah uh twitter my dms are open
i'm
so bad at social media but uh i will
i'll get
back eventually but my dns are open
um and then yeah and then um
yeah that's that's probably the best way
besides coming to visit me
terrace park ohio
excellent um so thank you to free code
camp for
for letting me take over the stream uh
this has been
so much fun i really enjoy everybody
thank you to everybody in the chat who
asked great questions um keep in mind
we do these on fridays so we'll be back
again next friday uh
with i believe april spite is going to
be on next week which i'm
super excited about uh so mark your
calendars
make sure that you go and uh and you
know get the
i think quincy will post the article
here shortly to for everyone to go
follow up
if you want to do more live coding um i
run a live coding stream
every week on tuesdays and thursdays
it's called learn with jason
it's on twitch learnwithjason.dev is
where the schedule is where past
episodes are
and you can come learn something with me
in 90 minutes
and on that note i think we're going to
call this one in the can tara thank you
again
chat thank you again we'll see